- [Kelly] Social media is
filled with tons of great posts.
My job is to make sure
you don't miss the best.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
7 year old Rowan wants to make sure
other kids never feel
alone in their worries.
This video makes me cry every time.
So he's been making videos
to uplift his friends and
classmates with his
impressive words of wisdom.
Just check him out in action.
- [Rowan] Hey second grade
friends before we was
in first grade. But now, since we're going
into second grade, I want you guys to know
that it's going to be really fun,
but make sure you be kind, not be rude,
don't be obnoxious or anything like that.
And believe in yourself.
- (crowd cheers)
- I love that he said "obnoxious"
'cause you can tell he's heard a parent
say that or something.
(laughs) That's awesome.
He's such an old soul,
right? He's so cute.
We have Rowan on the line,
along with his mama, Michelle.
So Rowan, what's up?
- [Michelle] Hi
- So Rowan, what inspired you
to start making these videos?
- Well, I used to be picked on in school
about having a unibrow so I started making
these videos and I came home crying to
see mommy. And since we talked, we,
we got to make these videos and
people got to learn from it.
- And Michelle, you must be so proud.
I was literally just talking
to Kathy about it's like the
greatest compliment when
you know your kids are like,
oh my God, somebody says
that your kid is kind,
it's like the best compliment I think
that you can hear about your child.
- Absolutely. Oh my God.
It just touches me so much
because he's always been such a
sweet kid. He's just a sweet soul.
He's an old soul and for
everybody to see it and for it to
actually be helping other kids
is really the best feeling.
(crowd claps)
- Some of the videos that he's been doing,
like they've had over 200,000 views.
People have been sending him
books about bullying and toys
and just the sweetest letters.
And it's the most amazing
feeling. I'm so proud of him.
- I'm proud of you. I just met your Rowan.
Well, Rowan, I usually close the show.
I close out the show by
saying have a great day.
And if it's not great change it.
What would you say to everybody?
- Stay kind and there's
no beautiful without you.
- I love you Rowan.
Well thank you so much,
Rowan and Michelle I'm
liking your posts right now.
- [Michelle] Thank you
so much, we love you.
- [Kelly] And that's not
all. Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly,
just like you Rowan. So there'll be using
their friction erasable pen to write
you a check for a thousand
dollars. How's that sound.
- (crowd cheering drowns out speaker)
- [Kelly] Yeah.